tell me about what are you planning
how's it going it's good fun I mean I we
do what we can when we can but we're not
to stress about it all we want is just
to have our family and our close friends
there so have you set a date picked a
dress any of that stuff I have not
picked a dress but we definitely set a
date so that's a good that's a step one
right so that's good that's just who I
had wanted to ask you about advice for
your brother for hairspray long he
doesn't need any advice or Mimas like
just have fun and like enjoy it and like
get to know the cast I wasn't in town I
was in Toronto but Derek had a party at
my house for all the the hairspray cast
so he's just embracing it and enjoying
it and it's it's so once-in-a-lifetime
kind of thing so I'm happy for now
before I let you go I got to put you on
the spot with dancing stars who was
taking the mirror ball oh my gosh you
are putting me on the fun and I don't
know that's the thing that's so cool
about the show is that even sometimes
the best dancer doesn't win because it's
all about the journey and how people are
connecting to them and I think we have
really really strong contenders there's
four of them that are just awesome so
you